[Music]
airships have always gotten people's
attention airships are magical they are
fascinating
whenever a film director or producer
wants to telegraph this is an alternate
reality you'll see an airship in the sky
we see that already
there are several airship projects that
are already being initiated
so it seems that the airship
industry has been reborn nearly a
century after falling out of favor
airships could be on the rise again
this time as a potential solution to one
of the most elusive problems in
aerospace
reducing emissions
a tremendous amount of the fuel burned
by an airliner is burned
simply to stay in the air and an airship
doesn't need to do that backed by new
research and technology companies are
aiming to take advantage of this free
lift to fill in some gaps underserved by
current infrastructure
and of course there's always the
excitement factor
it's something that is very attractive
to people as an idea it's a type of
aircraft that seems to generate an
emotional response but for airships to
go from alternative reality to a reality
they'll need to support a business case
that can overcome nearly a century of
failure
if you look at it every project ever
failed uh regardless of the station you
don't have a large airship in the sky
it's interesting that we don't look back
on things like the titanic as the end of
shipping because shipping has been an
economically viable and mainstream part
of our transport networks ever since
the first thing to reshape that
narrative on the technology is to make
it an economically viable proposition
[Music]
a century ago airships dirigibles and
zeppelins were at the cutting edge of
luxury transport
ferrying passengers non-stop across the
atlantic ocean decades before the jet
age
today the number of active airships has
dwindled to a few dozen worldwide mostly
used for novelty rides or as floating
billboards
but a handful of brave companies around
the world are trying to make them into a
more common sight in the skies
some like lta research funded by google
co-founder sergey brin
have been rather secretive about their
plans
other companies have only released
computer generated visions of what they
hope to build
a few however have been able to actually
fly a prototype it is the largest
aircraft in the world
makers boasted that they had created a
new breed of hyper-efficient aircraft
this is the airlander 10 endearingly
nicknamed the flying buttocks
it makes up for what it lacks in style
by offering what could be one of the
greenest ways to travel by air
using around 1.2 million cubic feet of
lighter than air helium the craft can
cruise at a top speed of about 80 miles
per hour originally designed as a
surveillance platform by the us military
the project was canceled in 2013 but
uk-based manufacturer hybrid air
vehicles would eventually reacquire the
project to bring it to market so it's a
carbon fiber construction and as you can
see as you come in here into the flight
deck element there's loads of space here
if you're the pilot your view out
is is amazing
from an aircraft development perspective
you can do a huge amount on paper you
can do a huge amount in simulation and
wind tunnels
but it's getting a new configuration
into flight that's the big milestone
because you learn a lot
its second test flight left some
onlookers feeling let's just say
deflated
oh my god
thankfully far from the worst airship
disaster of all time the airlander
eventually returned to the skies for
more testing since 2017 this airlander
10 prototype resides mostly in pieces at
hav's headquarters just over an hour
outside london as troubling as it looks
falling ideally more gracefully is
actually a key feature of how the craft
flies as the company name hybrid air
vehicle suggests airlander is what's
known as a hybrid airship that is
achieving lift from a combination of
conventional airship design
and aerodynamic attributes from other
flying aircraft the principal element at
play is helium the lighter-than-air gas
that has the added perk of being
non-flammable unlike the hydrogen that
doomed the infamous hindenburg just like
a toy balloon with enough helium the
ship will rise essentially free lift
the trouble with three lift is it's
always there
and so we had to find a way of
making the aircraft work more easily in
terms of how things were loaded onto it
and off it and
made the operation for the
whoever's flying it easier we've done
that by making the aircraft generate
aerodynamic lift so it takes off and
lands
like a conventional aircraft although in
a really short space
that lift is effectively only lifting
the payload that's the easiest way to
think of it
this means that without the aerodynamic
lift the craft is actually heavier than
air more like an airplane without the
lift generated by forward motion the
airship sinks down and more importantly
stays on the ground and the reason
that's important is because getting on
board and off-board an airplane taking a
shipping container on board or off for
an airplane it's it's a lot easier if
you're on the ground
some of the large
airships would use you know ground crews
of up to 500 people to
get them out of hangars and move them
around even the smaller airships of
today have got significant ground crew
with a hybrid aircraft we're on the
ground for that loading and unloading
cycle it allows us to turn the aircraft
around quickly and drive the economics
the economic performance of the aircraft
as an asset this means the craft can
take off and land from any reasonably
flat surface like grass water or even
ice
and according to hav the base model that
uses four combustion engines will reduce
co2 emissions by 75 percent over
comparable aircraft
and future plans to have a hybrid
electric engine would reduce emissions
by 90 percent
with the goal to eventually create a
truly emissions-free craft
hiv believes that this combination of
technologies will make airlander both
eco-conscious and economically viable
for applications ranging from
surveillance logistics cargo transport
and even passenger travel when i think
about passenger transport it's such an
exciting
space to move a technology like this
into because it can change our
expectations
[Music]
right now if we want to make a journey
here in the uk say from
the north west of the uk to uh to
ireland we've got a body of water to
cross and our choices are to travel out
to an airport do a very fast but very
short flight and then travel back in
from the airport at the other end
or we can get on a ferry that's
three times the journey length
and the right thing to do here from a
carbon footprint perspective is to get
on the ferry but it's such a time
impact for people with airlander what we
offer is almost a high-speed train of
the sky
added to that
the aircraft will go point-to-point it's
not constrained to airports that we have
today so like a helicopter it'll take
off and land away from the airport so we
can open up a whole new journey
i mean an obvious example is going
to the north pole
hev advertises that airlander will be
able to carry passengers to remote areas
like the north pole on three-day
excursions covering up to 2000 nautical
miles at cruising speeds of around 60
miles per hour
a bit like with a helicopter you can
similarly take helicopters to almost
anywhere but the range of a helicopter
is very short whereas you know we could
go on a three-day cruise if you like
with a stop at the north pole
their first commercial target is to
bring this experience to the luxury
travel market so i'm sat here in our
leisure um cabin demonstrator here
with the bar with social spaces and what
you can't see is down at the other end
of this cabin from where i'm sat there
are
eight double bedrooms for overnight
cruises
this allows the leisure sector to offer
their clients experiences that you just
can't get anywhere else their approach
harkens back to the early 20th century
when luxurious airships were the premium
option for well-heeled passengers on
transatlantic journeys
but building a sophisticated looking bar
and filling it with an impressive wine
selection
is still a far away from a happy hour in
the skies
a luxury travelers who are going to be
paying a tremendous amount of money are
probably going to compare this maybe to
a cruise ship they're used to having a
private bathroom with their bedroom
they're used to doing things like taking
showers and
you know using water in the sink
you need to
cater to their needs with a relatively
high staff to passenger ratio if you're
going to deliver a luxury product
and everything i just mentioned
is heavy a cruise ship on the ocean
doesn't really need to worry so much
about
the weight of things you always have to
look at the alternative we're going to
use an airship or we're going to use x
right so let's say x is a high speed
rail line so if you look at a place like
europe
high speed trains can connect city
center to city center
and high-speed trains go a lot faster
than any airship can they carry a lot of
people they're
very environmentally friendly
our airship's beautiful and magical and
wonderful of course they are right but
is a high-speed train line make more
sense to go from berlin to hamburg yeah
it probably does and in fact it almost
certainly does have though believes
airlander can serve a gap in areas where
such infrastructure is lacking at a much
lower cost yeah we've got hugely
invested high-speed rail infrastructure
in europe
there's lots of parts of the world where
a lot of movements over water
there's a lot of parts of the world
where we've got big geographic
boundaries mountain ranges and so forth
and so in both of those cases you know
the ability to put
ground surface infrastructure is
constrained you know big infrastructure
programs needed if you're going to open
up high-speed rail big infrastructure
programs if you're going to tunnel under
the sea rather than fly over it where
airlander can step in with a very
infrastructure light solution and an
experience and a travel experience
that's very equivalent to a high speed
rail of the skies
beyond passenger travel the prospect of
low emission transport without the need
for major infrastructure could also have
a profound impact in another space
cargo
[Music]
this is the lta 60t an airship with a
cargo capacity of up to 60 tons making
it even larger than ajv's airlander 10.
it's the dream of paris-based company
aptly named flying whales
the reason why we created flying wells
is actually to solve a major issue we
have in france
forest industry was the second
contributor to the french trade balance
deficit because we have a lot of
resources but there is no returning
investment to build roads and tracks to
pick up the lugs and bring it to the
sawmill so we had to invent in solution
to go by the air with funding from the
french government flying whales began to
develop an airship that could fly into
the remote mountains of france to
retrieve logs for processing into lumber
as you might guess from only seeing
computer-generated renderings the
company has yet to build a full
prototype
but they believe that after nearly a
decade they're getting close so we've
been through
something like four years of what i call
de-risking phase on technology markets
it's actually intimately it's half a
billion euro project and you you have to
be sure about what you do when you
invest so much money and in
2017 we were pretty much all convinced
and then we actually
launched the engineering project
so here is the the global view you can
see
the external shape details here the
stations for the propellers
on the left side on the right side and
also the stations for rosette propellers
we are very huge 200 meters in length
and 50 meters in height
and we have a rigid body which means we
don't change shape
according to the environmental
conditions
this model of the lta 60t is designed to
carry wood logs but the company believes
it can also be used to efficiently carry
other cumbersome cargo like high voltage
towers or wind turbine blades
transporting large bulky items on
today's infrastructure let's just say
can run into some challenges
and for remote areas like northern
canada it could open up entirely new
industries and resources in regions
lacking traditional land or air
infrastructure but with airships loading
and unloading cargo has a big technical
caveat
the load exchange problem in an airship
carrying cargo is that when you release
the cargo and you release its weight
what's going to stop the airship from
just popping up into the sky because
it's now a lot lighter so you've got to
exchange that load somehow
there are a few different ways to
overcome this the most obvious solution
might be to dynamically adjust the
quantity of gas
but helium while much safer than
hydrogen is also much more expensive to
acquire
so adding and releasing large quantities
during each flight isn't economically
feasible
but there may be another physics-based
solution here by compressing or
decompressing the helium
you could change the airship's lift
while in flight this is ultimately the
best solution and some of our
competitors
are trying to develop these uh the
problem we have with this solution that
it's very heavy compressor and tanker
are very heavy so it needs a lot of r d
and i think this technology is going to
be available in something like five to
ten years
until then another option is offsetting
weight with engine thrust
but this would largely defeat the
efficiency benefits of an airship in the
first place
instead flying whales is considering a
more balanced solution
if a trip calls for transporting say 30
tons of wind turbine blades it would
need to pick up another 30 tons to
replace the weight after drop off with
the help of thrusters to help compensate
during the transfer process
in the example of retrieving wood from
remote regions it would need to carry
the equivalent weight in water on the
trip out
then dispense that water dynamically as
it lifts wood in order to achieve
balance
which visually at least kind of looks
like a flying whale
in theory it can be simple
but impractical it is not because it's a
dynamic period
and during this dynamic period you have
to be very careful
on the equilibrium between buoyancy and
weight
as if this didn't sound complicated
enough airships face another major
vulnerability
weather the side of an airship is like a
giant wall it's like a giant sail and
there is something we call sail effect
if you have a really really big airship
even a gentle wind
multiplied by the huge expanse of the
side of an airship
can really move that airship in a way
that it can't move a smaller vehicle
like a small airplane
to compensate for wind the lta-60t has a
series of propellers positioned all
around the aircraft these axes help us
to control the airship in a longitudinal
vertical and a directional way this
ultimately limits application to areas
with stable enough weather conditions
where this weight exchange can safely
occur despite all of these obstacles
flying whales still envisions a viable
application for airships
transports business is very tough
there is a lot of competition so margins
are very small so it's useless to try to
come with a new solution say okay look
guys we're going to replace what you do
because we have a green solution or
locker solution now that doesn't work
when the system is already existing in
the transport solution without margin
you cannot replace it so we just look at
where we really provide a huge gap in
terms of cost or capacity regarding the
existing
and in addition of course we will
strongly reduce the environmental impact
the niche that flying whales is
targeting is currently served by a more
common sight in the sky
helicopters
based on benchmark tests flying whales
claims that their airship could save 15
times the carbon emissions and carry
three times more payload than the best
performing heavy lift helicopters while
still being cheaper to produce
the helicopter has been developed
to to transport
very uh very fast people
from point a to point b i mean
planes have been developed to go very
fast very
very far okay in our case we are
something like a flying crane
we are today the
designer of the airship but tomorrow
will be the producer and the operator so
in the future our business model will be
based on two things the the production
and direct sale of the airship by flying
wells industry and the transportation
services provided by flying well
services
flying whales hopes to be flying their
airship by late 2024
in the meantime they will test and
finalize their design while working with
aviation regulators to approve the
designs for flight
you know building any new aircraft
getting any brand new aircraft design
certificated by the you know
certificating authorities
is a very very expensive project
now when you're building on a previous
iteration of something you know you're
turning a 7
57 into a 767 or 727 into a 737
you're still certificating new aircraft
it's still a lot of engineering it's
still a lot of expense
but you're starting with something
building an airship in the 2020s
is sort of starting with a blank slate
because nobody's had a giant airship
since the 1930s
but what if money isn't everything at
least in the beginning
achieving our goals and preserving the
planet might take a mix of ingenuity and
adopting unconventional approaches
and that begins with niche applications
of new unproven and even unprofitable
tech for the time being at least
the two challenge you have is first to
prepare your shareholders
it's gonna be very long it's gonna cost
a lot
okay and the second thing which is
actually one of my major challenge is
to keep your team motivated when you
have a young engineer coming in the
company and after two years three years
five years
six years you have to tell them well you
still have four years before you're
going to see that flying it's very
difficult we are seeing a lot of
companies talk about airships we're not
seeing a lot of companies building
airships there are things that an
airship can do better than anything else
it's just that there are not very many
of those things right it's always going
to be a niche player if it's going to be
a player at all
it's going to fill a very very narrow
niche
coming into this business and leading
this business it's been really really
important to
build our understanding and build our
customers understanding and finances
understanding of the market gap that
exists that we don't usually spot
because it's a gap we're not good and
attuned at seeing gaps until after
somebody comes and puts a product into
them in aviation we're dream makers and
dream deliverers and you get it right
and that's true but you get the
economics wrong and it's not
you